good evening good evening members
members of the members of um oh no no
members of the public coming here
tonight officers
um I'd like to welcome you to tonight's
performance governance and audit
committee meeting on Thursday the 29th
of September 2022 my name is councilor
Wendy stamp and I'm the chairman of this
committee members we are streaming this
meeting live as well as recording and by
being present in this meeting you are
given your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can I ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when you finished please
reference a page and paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers and
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
gender item 2 members apologies for
absence
um Berner can I have apologies for
absence please
thank you and I've received apologies
from absence from
um Mr Dodson
thank you
um moving on members minutes it is
recommended that the minutes of
performance governance and audit
committee meeting held on the 21st of
July 2022 found on pages five to eight
are approved as a true and accurate
record I so move do I have a second for
that motion thank you
um
cancer Thompson
um does any member wish to raise any
matter of accuracy they need to put
their hands up to indicate and speak
now
um so can we agree that by Ascent
members
agreed Verner thank you
moving on Declarations of interests to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
vegetable interests and non-registerable
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda have in regard to
paragraph 9 and appendix B of the code
of conduct for members members are
reminded that they are also required to
disclose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
through throughout the meeting
now we're having a little bit of change
around today members as you can see
um I've been accommodated by moving this
next item up the agenda because I think
it's important and I didn't want people
sitting around like the um Chris what's
his name Chris Chris Andre
um who's going to be speaking so a
gender item five exclusion of the public
and press to resolve that under section
100 a little four of the Local
Government Act 1972 the public be
excluded from the meeting for the
following item of business on the
grounds that they involve and likely to
disclose and exempt information as
Divine defined in paragraph three of
part one of schedule 12a to the ACT and
that this satisfies the public interest
test I propose do I have a seconder
up yet councilor um Thompson again
okay
so we just have to wait
um members and
the screen comes back on you'll be able
to turn your microphones on you'll be
able to listen to us after this private
confidential item
foreign
notification from the streamers I think
yes yes
oh it's on now thank you
um thank you gender item number seven
resumption of business in the open Forum
um thank you members let's move on now I
can um members I'm getting myself in a
bit of a tizzy today aren't I
um public participation
um to receive the views of members of
the public of which prior notification
in writing has been received no later
than noon on Tuesday prior to the day of
the meeting and I can report that we've
got no public participation members so
we can move on
um right I think today it's going to be
a misused show I hope you've got your
tea and your cakes ready misused because
I think you've got a lot of reports to
present tonight
um and the first one is and the review
of the corporate performance quarter one
um I'll let you do the report and then
I'll do the recommendations misuse thank
you
so uh this report covers the corporate
plan thematic strategies and the
commercial strategy performance as at
the end of quarter one and which covers
April to June
2022. uh section 3.3 is a covering
report highlights a summary of
performances at the end of quarter one
and it's only the prosperity strategy
where the outcomes have been marked at
risk and these are highlighted in your
pack
section 3.4 then drills down further and
shows specific indicators that have been
marked at risk within each strategy the
data Behind These summaries is then set
out in your appendix which is Pages 41
to 62 of your agenda pack
page 63 63
starts the first inclusion of the
commercial strategy reporting so the
full template is provided for committee
visibility but some of the measures will
start to be updated on this world from
Quarter Two
the commercial projects that contribute
to the overall delivery and their
current status are reported within this
Amanda there has to review the reports
and confirm Assurance on performance
being managed effectively and I'm happy
to take and direct any questions uh
thank you masseuse I'm just going to say
something before Council stilts comes in
um I think that the last meeting we had
we asked if the colors could be a little
bit easier to see when I was looking at
all the charts and the lines and I know
everybody knows I'm having struggling
with them a little eyesight problems I'm
really struggling to see the light
greens and the difference in changes and
tones could that be taken on board
please yeah thank you cancer stilts
oh thank you madam chair I've got quite
a few questions
um page 44
and I know it's not started yet but it's
the question it's the delivery of
management plan for all Malden District
Council and public spaces
um as per the kpi for the performance
Park management plan no additional
Finance or staff resources have been
allocated in order to this be initiated
can you tell me when this project is
likely to be initiated
um Mrs do you have that information
Miss Green
thank you Miss green can you answer that
question
um let's go to Mr Leslie while miss
green she's maybe thinking she's on show
later because
oh
Mr Leslie go
yeah thank you chair um I think with
this you know we've had a discussion the
um reports have come to council around
about
um how we're going to look at resources
in certain areas um going forwards so I
think that will form part of part of the
plan
um for the future which has been
reported to council so it'll be wrapped
up in in that is my understanding but uh
Miss green that may have
Miss green can you answer councilor
stilts please thank you yes that's
correct yes do that joke so we don't
have a time
um
was it there a time frame at the moment
for the
SE in
further report to council April
so it won't be starting this until April
cancer stilts
thank you madam chair that is quite
disappointing to hear that we're going
to be waiting till April for that to be
started
um I do have some more questions so uh
page 46 and it's the air quality
management statement which is at risk
um
and my question is when can we expect to
get this back on track because this has
now been suspended and we all know
Market Hill is one of the worst popular
uh polluted
um areas in the dish
um
Miss green is that you again
uh no members but I'm very happy to to
provide an update after the meeting for
you does any any officer that's on
yeah
yes thank you chair um there are
discussions happening around the air
quality we have been very short with
resources to be able to support those
projects but discussions are happening
with the view to getting that back on
track again
um we've got some funding that we are
using to support the air quality
programs and I know a conversation
happened just last week with County so
I'll be able to provide some more
details after this meeting in terms of
what activities we have planned over the
coming months okay that'd be great if
you could actually Supply that to all
members that'd be good um Council fluke
who is in relation to this question if
not it is and you know this was a really
well worked up thing a few years ago and
then covered came along and it came off
the radar so I think you know to
understand what's been going on with
this we need to go back
pre-covered to see where we actually
were I think that's not two fingers
you're waving
and uh
um yeah so you know I I agree with
cancer stilts this was you know we'd
invested a huge amount of certainly time
in it we had lots and lots of meetings
about this and we got this to a really
good place
and it's just dropped off the radar and
I mean I've been up and down Market Hill
a couple of times in the last week and
it's you know it's getting very very
busy again and and I think also since
that piece of work started we've had the
Blackwater uh retail parks open and
you've got all these lovely people
um sitting out uh Costa Coffee and one
thing I wouldn't agree with councilor
stilts on it's not one of the most
polluted areas in in the district it's
one of the most polluted areas in the
county and you've got people sitting
outside uh on the pavement this is an
urgent piece of work and we moved it so
far forward it would just it would be
terrible not to take advantage of where
we got to before so I hope when this
report comes back
um we're going to see where we got to 18
months two years ago and how we can move
that forward quickly because I do know
that Essex were Keen to to sort this
problem out thank you um councilor
Fleming foreign
I was just going to chip my two pennies
and my understanding of where we are now
so we were waiting for a transport uh
assessment to be undertaken
by Essex and then that has now been uh
broadened out to include the whole
District so
which I mean I think we've all been
invited to a meeting haven't we there's
a briefing so I mean when I heard that I
sort of
sense of dread came over me because I
thought well that's that this is going
to take forever now
um so yeah that that is my understanding
of where it is now
um okay thank you with respect that was
done and before because we had the
receptors in various places in the
district so that was done and the other
place which was incredibly close to
being at the danger level was actually
the the
the roundabout in latchingdon by the
church and that really really was but
and I can remember we did a huge amount
of work on this and Essex will have it
all
um so you know I do hope that we don't
spend six months going over doing things
that we've already done
I think we will await the report with
interest I think um
um cancer Thompson is a new new question
because cancer stilts is still
sorry not really only to say that we are
working with Essex County Council on the
transport strategy okay Council of the
channel and I attend different workshops
thanks thank you cancer stilts please
thank you
um I agree with
um councilor Fluker I think you know
helpful well-being and we've got people
breathing in all these fumes it's it's
awful
um I will move to page 51 page 51.
um the economic future an economic
investment and new jobs is at risk
um what are we doing as a council to
reach our local businesses to improve
business satisfaction in the district
you know it's great saying it's at risk
but what are we actually doing to
improve
that risk
is who's that Miss Wheatley
is that one for you please
answer that one in committee so okay
okay are you happy with that Council
stilts we'll all have the reply yep
thank you next one Council stilts
fine
foreign
53 I think I've got it slightly wrong
there which was the at-risk the
enhancing and promoting the district's
economic visitor or the visitor economic
we talk about
um some of these lovely big events we
put on
but our district is
basically not just big events how are we
going to support tourism in our district
which is not just big events they are
we're talking about for the long term
our tourism is one of our Vital things
in this District so why is this at risk
um who's going to do that is that so you
you Cheryl for Mr Dodson
and Mr Leslie's going to come in first
I think with with part of the visitor
number and from the comments you know
it's an era that's obviously been hit by
covid is what we're saying to to the
economy and that's why it's at risk and
actually are we seeing people returning
we've seen large numbers return to the
prompt part we've seen a bit of changing
habit and you can tell that from the
sort of the parking numbers within that
area so we are seeing quite a good
return I think in recent events
you've seen that because of covid
although events are coming back we heard
General across the country there's been
a bit of a lag of uptake and seems to be
a bit of a saturation in some of events
which has happened and we've seen that
perhaps with ticket sales and our own
events hasn't been quite quite as high
so that remains uh at risk but we hope
that once that levels out and with some
work we should see a return to normality
the pre-covered times as well so I think
that's that's why we're flagging it at
risk at the moment around that
cancer stilts I'm just going to come
back on that seeing as that we are now
going into a very uncertain future for
the amount of money that people have got
in their pockets
um how do we feel that that is going to
impact Upon Our tourism and what
measures are we taking as a council to
ensure that we do everything we can I
think if you don't mind me adding to
that I think that's fair comment thank
you Mr Leslie thank you yes I absolutely
I'll ask it that's another Factor what
puts it at risk apps absolutely I mean
it was certainly doing for our residents
um we're doing activities around
supporting our residents through the
cost of living crisis as well as County
Council
um as well so we've got certainly the
web page which details some of the help
and support that's available in terms of
a residence regarding the economy that's
obviously a piece of work that's going
to be ongoing as well around engagement
with businesses
Etc around that so I think that's a very
good point very challenging times and
how we engage and how we promote it as a
district as well as important and then
we are engaging with Essex County
um Council as well in terms of the
overall uh for Essex
um area so I think we took the tying in
as best we can as well
any more cancer stilts
yeah I've got a few more but if the I'll
go to council Thompson I'll give you a
chance to take a glass of water and just
catch your breath and then I'll come
back to you Council Thompson thank you
chairman yes this is relevant to the
item we were just talking I'm sure
you'll get more detail from misuse when
she comes back but you know we have a
sense of place at the North Essex
economic board and also Mr Ellum is
working with businesses so there is
stuff happening I would be very
interested to ask councilor still
through you chairman if she has any
information coming out of the tourism
body that I believe she sits on
do you sit on the tourism body and have
you got any information that you can
impart to the committee uh yes I do sit
on the tourism body and we had two
meetings
um we will wake Tim for the terms of
reference to be drawn up
um and I don't think Alexis
um has actually called another meeting
for quite a while now so I'm waiting for
another meeting to be called
thank you any more questions before um
hang on Council Fleming and then
councilor Edwards am I next yes you're
next
um I was just going to comment actually
about
um the Queen's baton
um and the ride London I personally
don't think that they were terribly well
publicized don't know whether anyone
else feels the same
um
would be a comment that I would make
um I don't know who whose fault that is
um
the Queen's bat on I mean what did we do
for that
I must admit that one person ride London
I knew a lot about because I was
interesting because we had it in our
division didn't we cancel fluka the
previous one the cycle ride whatever it
was called that was brilliant the ladies
yeah we did it they came past my house
counselor for uh fluka yeah and sorry my
and my other comment about a supporting
business I I think that business looks
at the council as an obstacle uh not
necessarily a facilitator if I'm being
brutally honest with people and I think
we do have to be careful that when we
have money passed from central
government we don't just use that to
employ another officer to write another
policy document you need to deliver
tangible things on the ground it's just
a comment I would make about that thank
you hopefully that's been heeded by
whoever needs to heed it Mr Leslie
um cancer Thompson
sorry me again chairman thank you um if
I didn't know differently I would
actually said the ride London just
regards Malden was much more
a thing than the district I'm not quite
sure what happened there
but I think something did in fact go a
bit awry with
I think with the
perception of who was organizing we we
had presentations here didn't we we we
had a I think I went to about three
different or at least four presentations
on ride London but was anyone invited uh
High Street and numb hands up yes well
yes we did but did the public I mean I'm
not even sure if the chairman of the
district council was involting I don't
know no no no council stilts
yeah the um modern turn Council were
involved with a lot of the ride London
for the fact that they used the miracle
um but the roads that were shut off was
Essex County Council
um and I do know that there was officers
from Modern District involved with it
but it was all the Olympic Committee in
Essex County Council as far as I was
aware the Baton coming through was
arranged to go into the park which the
chairman attended
um it's coming back anyway bad London
it's next year as well so I know that
yeah I would just like to comment yeah I
mean I think probably I mean I fielded
emails complaining about it
um quite a lot of emails complaining
about it
um
but then but then I didn't really sort
of hear oh well this is where it's going
to be you can so that that's just my
comments on it thank you okay right
let's move on members I think we're all
going to go to sleep let's get some life
back into this meeting we're all getting
a bit slow cancer stilts thank you page
60.
um C 21 percentage of MDC customer
facing staff who have raised received
make every second count training
um why have we only reached 63 of our
staff to have this important customer
training
is that your misused yeah she's ready
look she's
changing stuff and that they haven't had
the training yet so hopefully those
steps will be improved according to two
okay
thank you I think my next questions are
on Quarter Two okay members anything
else
uh Council Edwards please
thank you chairman
um page 62 please
um number of Parish and town councils
working with the community engagement
team
at a recent haber's price cancer meeting
this week
the price Council reviewed their service
level agreement and concluded that it
was not being met by the CET team and
therefore given notice to terminate
their contact with the community
engagement team as from the 31st of
October
um some of the reasons being I
understand
but like a lack of resources regarding
vacancies and internal structure in
internal structuring so I just wanted to
to point that out that as I say no
longer 20
each quarter no longer on track and
habe's price cancer have withdrawn as
I've just mentioned thank you
um
Miss green would you like to comment on
that because I think you was at the
pre-meet when I raised questions and
concerns myself about what's actually
happening with the CET
um and I will declare that Bernard
Croucher also
um thinking about possibly terminating
due to
the service that looks like it's been
depleted and gone in different
directions due to whatever reason and I
think it's quite a a serious comment and
a serious thing that we need to address
as a council so if if you would like to
step in we would really appreciate your
comments thank you
um I have to say there have been no
significant formal issues that have been
raised previously and we have reached
out to the parish council as we do with
all that we end down councils that we
deal with and the reason that we've been
given is that the Heritage parish
council do not feel that the contract
used to have been done for money
um so because it was a great
disappointment and um we are looking to
see from Hermitage approach cancer
specifics of why they feel that it
wasn't too different value for money
um and yes the team have her vacancies
but we are able to deliver
um in very large parts to the contracts
that we have delivered it's fairly rare
that we're not able to deliver the hours
and we are starting to live in the
activities that are in the service of an
agreement
and we have set up some forums with the
parish councils and term councils that
we work with to be able to engage
directly with them as well as individual
meetings so again if any time or Parish
Council has any concerns we're very
happy to have one-to-one meetings and
discuss exactly what those issues are
um thank you I'll come to council fluke
in a moment um you will be um Burnham
Town Council had a meeting on Tuesday
and they are actually going to ask
um you guys to actually come and have a
meeting with them because um like I did
say they're seriously looking at
terminating and if you terminate the
both con of both contracts term that's a
lot of money that will go from this
Council and you know Miss green that I'm
very unhappy that I feel that we're
losing the community sense of community
because the guys aren't there doing what
they always used to do but that's that's
obviously my comment counselor fluka
please thank you chairman I I'm sorry
did you want to come back I mean look
southminster withdrew as well now I
think it's a great shame
um but you know we we spoke to the
council about providing some kind of
cover for our annual fireworks show
um where we get about at least a
thousand people go to it
um and unfortunately we weren't able to
develop a working relationship over that
but
the community engagement team my
understanding is is that they're often
used to put up planning notices is that
correct
let me scream
s part of the economic structure so if
you just allow me to come back so
when somebody makes a planning
application they pay a fee is part of
that fee being transferred over to the
community engagement team because it
concerns me enormously that if it isn't
then they're underfunded for doing the
rest of their jobs when they're actually
doing the job for the planning
department
and my understanding was was that one of
the reasons why the planning staff put
up the notices was because they would go
to the site and have a look
um but anyway I'm grateful to the answer
I'm not expecting a full answer now my
screen but you know I think it's you
know you talk about
you talk about pressures on department
but when you've got pressures that are
caused by interdepartmental engagement
in other words one Department's doing
another Department's job it's got to be
done fairly
let me scream
um I I just go back to again the the
work that was done with Ignite and the
process was reviewed and it was
considered through the the reviews of
the process that it was more efficient
for that to be done as part of the
community engagement activity as they
were doing that I think they were out
and about in the community anyway
Council photo do you want to come back
or no it's all about speeches
cancer Thompson
um thank you chairman um actually I'd
like to put in a word for the community
engagement team certainly in the smaller
parishes the ones in my award which is
nearly all smaller parishes
um most of the engagement is around the
speeding issues and
we catch phenomenal we
thought it was a very large we catch
phenomenal numbers of people speeding
through our Villages and we're very
grateful for the service and very
pleased with it and I just wish the
drivers took a bit more notice but there
you go thank you I don't think it was a
criticism of the team and the the people
who are operating truecam
um they luckily we managed to get them
back because of the service level
agreement changed at Burnham on Crouch
and they're thinking last week or the
week before they stopped 57. just on one
and most of them was on the Malden Road
and South Mr Road as well now so they do
a fantastic job thank you um I hope
that's answered your questions right
cancer stilts one more and then we're
going to move on to the recommendation
I've got a couple more a couple more and
then we're going to move on remember as
well we're going to be page 65 and I'm
sure that councilor fluka will come in
with this one Burnham and the houseboats
burn them on crouched they're in red
um
where are we with this um houseboats
um thing for Burnham on Crouch
um I think Mr butcher's not here but uh
Mr Leslie do you want to take that and I
know we had an update at a recent
meeting I'm sure I was at a meeting
um where it was discussed and we were
waiting on councilor fluke raised a very
important point about the MMO license
wasn't it full Council
um Mr Leslie
so yeah it is essentially a repeat of
what was said there uh really we're now
hopeful we've got some confirmation
um that there should be some activity
taking place
um soon we understand that they've got
their um uh licenses and agreements uh
in place obviously we are waiting
confirmation around this we'll keep it
we'll keep monitoring it and hope to
progress it very shortly I think we can
all appreciate it's been long and
perhaps we've expected it to move um in
the past as well but we are monitoring
it there is a plan and we hope it's
going to be executed um very soon
um cancer Fluker
you know this is a bit like the air
quality I don't get this because it says
on here that uh it mentions and securing
planning approval now I can remember
being at a meeting room we agreed to
appoint an architect to submit the
application to the council so you know
we've been waiting you know with baited
breath now I think at the southeast area
planning committee for about probably
three years so it's a year before covert
um you know Beggar's belief that we
haven't put in the planning application
you know you put your planning
application in and then we decide how to
deal with the less helic you know I mean
salesman I beg upon Council came up with
a pretty robust decision about the list
helic and how much we should be charging
which I'm sure Mr
um
Leslie will now confirm that from the
1st of October whenever we agreed they
will be paying that enhanced rate
um but this is you know what's going to
happen is is you know all of a sudden
you know the the Starship Enterprise is
going to fly over the Crouch and then
this Helix going to be beamed up and
then someone will say oh let's put in a
planning application
so we wait about four months for it to
be validated and then it toodles off to
Southeast and uh an environment agency
say no but we could have put that in two
and a half years ago to plan the
application because if we don't use it
we might find an operator that wants the
least a piece of land and do it
themselves but at the moment we've got
nothing
so it's hugely disappointed and I don't
buy the resources thing because all you
have to do is phone a planner and tell
them to make it work for a figure thank
you Council blue go to Mr Leslie but um
Mr Lee's actually on um on the on call
so on the screen I can see his picture
Mr Leslie do you want to go and then
we'll call on Mr Lee
foreign
so I can confirm the enhance rate has
agreed
um has been charged for that so that's
been charged in terms of uh the planning
yeah I think appreciate that um it
provides an opportunity as well to look
at uh what we're proposing the viability
around that given the increase in
construction costs and which route we go
down I think appreciate what has been
said uh around about the soon we go down
the planning route
um the better I think that we are sunk
cost obviously if we do that at the
moment uh and it may be a point to look
at the most viable option uh around that
um as well given we haven't spent that
money yet but I think the point is well
received uh the quicker we move on the
planning the better and Mr Lee may be
able to provide a bit more on that Mr
Lee are you going to turn your camera on
and join us
good evening
[Music]
you was in the pub you're in the pub you
you flushed up Mr Lee your secret is out
Mr Lee
[Laughter]
application has been in for some time
we've had a number of issues in relation
to documents being submitted for males
as an African we've had to get
additional information
and at the moment I think it is now the
question and we're waiting for
consultation response from Essex County
Council
so it has been it has been put forward
then has it
he's just waiting until you get all the
information Mr Lee before you actually
put down
for quite some time and we've gone back
to additional information on a number of
times and he did updated reports because
there have been out of date information
okay all right Mr Lee thank you yes uh
Mrs councilor Edwards
no everything
so it's something
oh cat's redwoods oh thank you chairman
oh staying on page 65 land acquisition
is there it's all green but do we have
any information about what land where
and how
is this something that the corporate
projects group's looking at or
is it something we ought to know about
because coming up to the ldp review that
should be um that would be a part of it
surely thank you
um I don't know who would like to speak
on that because I think some of it will
be most probably is it under green paper
some of it
Mr Leslie yeah my members have been
provided with details at uh PNC meetings
and also at the um working groups um as
well around updates from it
thank you but I'm not on a working group
Hall um
I think you'll be able to access
um the working group minutes
um so one of us will let you know which
working group I think the person to
speak to is
um
no which officer
um for them for um the minutes who where
this will be discussed
yeah contact we'll ask Charlotte or
somebody to contact you and get you the
minutes to where it's the PC is being
discussed thank you very much yeah okay
um Berna could you make a note of that
for me please
yes indeed of course the minister also
on my.gov but yes
the person I'm trying to remember was Mr
butcher he might be able to actually
Point him to which working group those
minutes were related to so I'm really
struggling people thank you so I know
exactly my question which work in group
learning yeah and Mr butcher will will
contact you thank you right members uh
Castle Fleming
thank you chair I wanted to
um have a suggestion of uh something
that we could add to uh this report for
Quarter Two I was hoping that we could
add
um for our corporate performance
overview that we could look at our
performance in retrofitting our housing
stock with insulation
um I know that some districts uh
well provide access to uh grants so I
was hoping show that we could put in
some sort of performance indicator of
number of residents assisted with
accessing grants
I will have a look into that I know
there is an indicator in the operational
balance scorecard around disabled
facility grants and but we'll look at
what date is available and and what's
available obviously noting that that
might fit better with the operational
balance scorecard report okay and
because this report is specific to the
corporate plan indicators and how we're
performing against those but then I'll
look at where we might be able to report
that thank you um thanks Cheryl because
I was sort of looking at the bit about
climate change and then I thought
actually well if we're going to look at
something terribly practical it would be
enabling our residents to access grant
funding to
you know retrofit insulation okay thank
you final question goes to councilor
stilts I feel like I've taken off all
the questions
um page 66 and 67 it goes across the two
it's the river bailiff Workshop
conversion to kiosk and the Promenade
plant Pavilion and whilst building a new
entry on the Promenade play part and the
Old River bay leaves is you know
understandable sadly we've just lost an
existing Atri on the part which is the
barge tea rooms which is closed
this was an existing tourist attraction
as well as nature how are we going to
support our existing eateries in the
park
um and also when you look at the
proposal for the covered one in the prom
play Park the proposals
does not have the resources allocated I
mean why
um I don't know who's going to take that
Mr Leslie and then misuse
oh yeah thank you
um so what we've got at the moment is
the uh bids to government for the the UK
um shepherdsbury fund and leveling up a
bit
um and that includes the um River
bailiff
um Hut and the kiosk as well so that
part
um will be tackled under that fundament
which you're waiting to have
confirmation from that will likely have
an implication on the surrounding areas
which includes the prom Park pavilion
area as well so maybe opportunities
around that and the play between that
side of it obviously the team can work
on a certain amount of projects but I
think it's what is wise to ascertain for
the level of funding we're going to have
available for that area and part of that
plan in terms of leveling up will be to
improve the surrounding areas which make
that more attractive increase visitors
and footfall Etc so part of that Central
area master plan and implementing that
is expected to have that in clinical
benefit to the locally are in existing
by bringing in increased tourism as well
so that's all part of that funding side
okay
um
yes you certainly can thank you can we
also make sure that if we do do these
buildings that we look at our climate
action because we do have a climate
action strategy for this Council and
that we make sure that these buildings
are carbon neutral as much as possible
and
that we have resources that are
renewable in them and also health and
well-being as councilor flu pointed out
earlier you know another burger store
um councilor fluka again there was you
know there was a
World worked up scheme
um
to bring another building forward in the
in the pond
um in partnership with um with a
well-known jam maker and the last thing
I heard was that they were still Keen to
do it but they hadn't heard anything
from Malden for two and a half years and
so when I was I was slightly amused on
page 68 I know we're
um running out a pound sterling but we
appear to be now using dollars
oh we are yes
I think that was never one would mind
you it's the same currency rate so it
doesn't really matter does it
um okay members let's let's move on
we're gonna go for the recommendations
the recommendations uh for the review of
corporate performance quarter one is
that members review the information are
set out in this this report and appendix
one with priority Focus given to the
Strategic outcome level performance
little two that members confirm that
they are assured through this review
that corporate performance has been
managed effectively I'd just like to put
a little Proviso on there as long as
that the comments that have been made at
this committee so far regarding this
agenda item is actually taken on board
because although we don't put amendments
to recommendations I think it's really
important that we are started to be
listened to and things are being
actioned and I would hope that that is
the case so I propose that do I have a
secondary please
um yeah cancer Fleming please do we
agree by Ascent members brilliant thank
you moving on to agenda item 10 I think
that'll be you again will it Cheryl
misused hang on a second let me catch up
please because I'm a okay so this is the
review of corporate risk quarter one the
purpose of this report is the risk
management policy requires this
committee to undertake a quarterly
review of the corporate risk register as
assurance that the corporate risks are
being managed effectively appendix one
is attached to the report so Mrs if
you'd like to take us through it please
yeah so this is the corporate risk
register at the end of quarter one so
that's June 2022
um appendix one is Page 71 to 79 and
that shows the full risk register and
commentary
um as set out in section three of the
covering report there is one risk that
is recommended for closure which is risk
13 failure to manage the impact of the
operation of operational change and this
is because operational resources and are
part of business as usual work and the
planning service report has been
separately reported to members so that's
why that's recommended for closure there
is also a new risk risk 33 which is lack
of temporary accommodation and special
housing to cope with housing demands and
this is because of several factors that
led to an increase in demand and
expected increase when the district
already has a limited supply of social
housing stock
members are asked to review and provide
feedback on the report and confirm
assurance that risk is being managed
effectively
uh thank you
um councilor Stevens please then
councilor stilts
thank you chair
um everybody's going to say this that
all of the risk ratings are unchanged
except for that one that's being removed
and the new one
um and I I just can't I understand that
I can't understand how nothing has
changed in a quarter
um and we've got a lot of words in some
of these commentaries but when you
really pick through it I'm not really
seeing what we're doing about the risks
so the new one risk 33 for
um regarding housing is a good example
as I think sometimes we get used to
these being on there oh yeah well that's
still there but if we look at r33 this
new one I can't see what we're doing
about it and having attended strategic
housing board today I can't see what
we're doing about it and I'd like to see
more than just a commentary that gives
us how we got here but what are we going
to do about it and what's expected to
change by the time I see the report next
time thank you thank you councilor
Thompson Thompson Council Stevens I
think the points are really well made
and I know I've only been in this chair
for a couple of meetings
um but I also feel exactly the same it's
it's great to produce all the reports
which is brilliant because I know we
have to do but what are we actually
starting to do to move these forward
because I've looked back at previous
meetings so I've got some history and
the risks aren't they're still read
there's hardly any movement so what are
we actually doing um I don't really
expect you to answer that you maybe
won't but if that could be passed back
to the directors
um we we would like I certainly would
like some update on that because we are
seeing a little bit of um I feel
stagnation for whatever reasons there's
no probably reasons but if we can
actually start to address some of them
it'd be fantastic
is
the further down the agenda we have the
revised risk management yeah and
engines and focus on mitigating actions
more because that's not something
that we're doing as part of the current
risk management policy so we are hoping
to address that in the latest iteration
and it is something that we're aware of
in terms of our processes thank you I'm
really really pleased about that um
councilor Stevens did you have any more
um no that's it really but just to make
sure that we're not just going to have
that commentary column but I'd like to
see them hopefully that's um what Miss
Hughes was just alluding to that we'll
have a separate column showing the
actions thank you thank you um I'm going
to go to council still it's then Council
fluke and then councilor Thompson
if councilor fluke is coming back on
this one then I'll give way to
know
I just I just wanted to say briefly on
this one look it's not changed and you
know to build on something that it was
said earlier on in the meeting you know
we are paying our directors and our
senior managers a huge amount of money
and it seems to me that every time
um we have an issue and particularly
around planning Services we've been
talking about this for three years and
it's only just now that we're going to
uh we're going to appoint a consultant
um who's going to come in and wave a
magic wand well we've been trying to
wave this magic mod and everything since
I've been on this Council though I think
it's fair to sound Mr Lawrence and Miss
Candler I think her name was we did move
things forward
um but you know the planning department
Mr Holmes is bringing forward you know a
new PC for planning Services Improvement
plan which you know I asked that should
be you know by way of emotion I think
that it will be reported back to Council
on a a regular basis like everything
every other motion that fell
um and and I think it's really important
to understand what's going on with
dependent upon because you know I don't
want to spoil Mr Lee's party but the
alternative is is to Outsource that
whole lot which a lot of councils do
very successfully and members might be
surprised that one of the companies that
do this hugely successfully is gladman's
which is where they started
you know we need to make some really
really big decisions about this because
you know I agree what councilor Stephen
says we nothing seems to move on
I don't think anybody can answer that it
was a comment so that's fine yeah cancer
stilts and yes I agree but having been
the chair of PG a I'm seeing stuff here
that was there when I was the chair
my question on R14 is why are we failing
to recruit the staff
um more importantly retain the staff
that we do have and do we still have an
exit questionnaire when the staff leave
us
I think that's because Mr Leslie
so yes we do have a
uctioneers they're still given out
um
two staff and fed back to the HR team
in terms of the Recruitment and
Retention side of it I think you know
part of the reason of engaging the LGA
is it's a national issue as well it's
not not specific to here particularly
around the plan inside of it
I think we will verse on that one of the
gay uh aims of part of the look at what
we can do is to make sure we've got a
structure which actually can one bring
forward trainees develop people have a
career a clear career path and
progression and understandable system
and also look at how we advertise
um as well and go out there and work
with the LGA to understand what's best
practice what Innovations can be done
and how can best work as a group as well
as some there's some talk about putting
together a recruitment area at a sort of
more uh Essex type level where we can
actually have that pool and recruit and
that's one of the ideas and one of the
reasons we're working with the LG and
decide because it is a national issue in
a few areas and not just specific to to
us
how's the stilts uh yes I did hear
cancer flu could just say that the
um leaving uh exit questionnaire was
reported to overview and scrutiny was
that right absolutely so why is it still
not being recalled reported to overview
and scrutiny
um Mr Leslie do you know that
okay I wasn't aware it used to be
um recorded there it hasn't been
um since since I've uh been been here I
think in terms of that side of it it's
um
often confidential information which HR
obviously have a look at and will raise
accordingly to that side of it so I
think there's a matter of
confidentiality that comes through as
well from that side and that's obviously
what goes to to HR
um I'll come in before cancer stilts
comes back on that um
take on board we all take on board
confidentiality but normally even if the
actual questionnaires are not reported a
report could be put together for key
learning objectives of why they're
leaving and that's that's often when you
can establish a pattern if there is a
pattern of what a culture could be
happening within an organization and
that's that's something that I'm sure
we're aware of at this Council and I
think it would be a very good exercise
to carry that out because we we seem to
be not retaining staff and once we get
them my view is I mean I when I worked
in the city they called me fair but firm
because they knew that they as long as
they worked they would be dealt with and
they would be looked after but they'll
be firm if they stepped out of line so
I'm sorry but no fair but firm but
that's what it was that's what they used
to call me
um anyway Mr Leslie could you take that
on board yes yeah I think I think the
absolutely right if that's um members
want that reported that's exactly the
right way to have it reported yeah
it was only a you know it was only a
summary I mean I I don't need to know
that who the person was that taught on
the rake and it hit them that we're
going to talk about later but it was
just somewhere in it and it was actually
you know it was actually quite useful
particularly when we used to get
comments like uh members always uh
overturned decisions and and things like
this you know it does make you think
um and I thought it was I thought it was
quite useful but it's it's this staff
retention I mean I was I was really
really pleased a few years ago when and
it was probably longer than that when
you know we we nurtured some staff in
the contact center and we made them
planners and then when they got to that
stage
um well I think from a corporate point
of view in my opinion they weren't
looked after and they just went
somewhere else to earn more money after
we trained them
um and these are the things you know
staff retention is absolutely important
but we've not been able to crack this
not Mr Leslie through you chairman for a
long long time and that's why I'm so
Keen to see Mr Holmes's plan I'm so Keen
for this new consultant that we've
appointed who's supposed to be looking
at the planning department to come to
council with a plan because if not we
need the nuclear option thank you um
cancer Fleming and cancer stilts
that kitchen I was just going to
disagree with councilor fluka's
suggestion that planning could be
outsourced
um I I don't agree with that I think
that we are the local planning Authority
if you take that away what do we do so
in terms of you know our statutory
roles
um and yeah I was going to say that back
up Mr Leslie's comments that it is a
national shortage every planning
Authority is experiencing the same I'll
also make the comment that I always make
is that personally the planning
department should not have been at home
Joe and covered or now they should be in
the office every day five days a week
it's a team thing you know you can't
expect younger officers to come and work
at home
um they need to be it's it's a skill and
they need to learn that they need to go
to meetings and watch their superiors
and they have got to be in the office
why would if you're a young officer why
would you come and work and sit at home
on the I mean how boring is that
um so yeah that's my comments thank you
and noted um cancer stilts please thank
you madam chair and I agree with
everything that you've you've said Madam
chair
um I wonder if it would be right for us
to make a proposal to say that the exit
questionnaires go to
overview and scrutiny to be
um looked at and to be discussed in that
committee
and if that is right to make a proposal
I would make that
um can I take advice on that because
obviously I um where would that come
under
um
Berner
because it's not actually
well you could we add it as a a
recommendation
um Cheryl or burner
so I wonder if the committee you could
put forward to one of the forms you can
send a link to the form because there's
a specific form that the committee that
would then review
consider whether they would add that as
a work plan item or a watch and brief
item okay I'm going to look to council
fluke because his is one of the best
yeah I mean my understanding is that
staff statistics used to get reported to
uh overuse scrutin I believe they still
do and part of that report it showed you
how many people left how many had
arrived and it also had the information
about this particular piece of work and
it's just dropped off and I don't bind
to the HR thing because it was never
attributed to any one person it was over
a 12-week period probably looking back
18 weeks so it was difficult to
attribute comments
um and I thought it was really really
useful so I don't think it needs I think
that report needs to be looked at and we
need to re-include it
or start included
cancer stilts
um Madam chairs my understanding is that
this committee can make recommendations
to move things to overview in scrutiny
yeah I just wanted to know where we were
going to put it
um so I'm more than happy to set that to
second that we just need um Cheryl will
it go as little full
just coming back
as a recommendation that overviews
GroupMe considers
as part of their work plan
okay
as parts of that plan okay members well
I think I've been any more questions one
question come on then yeah you're fed up
with me now that's fine um page 74 r29
failure to deliver Services as a result
of covid can you assure us that we are
now back on track for that or are we
still struggling with those services
um Mr Leslie
I think we've moved on to to a world of
new challenges and now the covered side
of it is you know uh not not really the
issue we're not with the staff
um uh absent as as much as before they
are note that uh there is still a few
cases um that we all experience at the
moment uh but the challenge obviously
has moved on from the covered side and
we're around the sort of
recruitment retention uh general staff
shortages for various reasons such as
you know we've had the hgv drivers for
example and general skill seals is in
planning Etc so I think the covid side
has passed we're perhaps on to a new set
of challenges
okay cancer Stills just one more
question you'll be pleased to hear that
and it's page 76 it's our four failure
to influence uh Community safety
Partners to address the key areas of
public concern why are we failing on
this one it's going to risk rate and
unchanged as orange but why haven't we
moved on why are we not
basically influencing this community
safety partners
um I don't know who would take that one
is that Miss Green
or Miss Wheatley
I think they've all gone gone home for
having their dinner
go on that's fine thank you
[Music]
so this isn't necessarily
[Music]
um's priorities it's actually about the
priorities for the whole partnership so
it's really important that we do have a
say at the table in terms of ensuring
that the priorities for our district are
built into that plan
um and certainly we do work very closely
with the community safety partnership
but it isn't something that we totally
have or totally control so I think
that's where those risks are because
Department partnership
so we don't have the control cancer
stills okay right members are we um are
we any more questions
no right so let's move to the
recommendations recommendation one that
members review the corporate risk
register in appendix one and provide
comments and feedback for consideration
which we've done recommend it too that
members are assured through this review
that corporate risk is being managed
effectively I think we've made notes of
everything members and excellent
questions little three that members
challenge risk where the committee feels
that the council's corporate goals may
not be achieved I think we've done that
and little four that overview and
scrutiny committee considers the exit
interviews as part of their work program
so they're going to look at that um miss
you as you said it better than me but if
you could actually make that sound
better
um it would be great but that was
basically the uh the um
meaning of it is that okay with you
okay so I propose those do I have a
seconder cancer stilts
members do we agree those
recommendations please thank you right
let's move on to a gender item 11.
um oh
um Miss Hughes you can have a break on
this one I don't think this is you
and this is the health and safety update
for quarter four 20 21 22 and quarter
one 22 23 the purpose of the report is
to provide a health and safety update
and the state statistics statistics and
activity during quarter one from the
first of January 22 to the 31st of March
22 and quarter one the first of April to
the 30th of June 2022. uh Miss Wheatley
would you like to uh present this report
please
yes of course thank you chair this is
the regular report to members on the
health and safety activity the report
covers the last quarter of the year
2021-22 and the first quarter of
2022-23 officers were unable to provide
her an update in June this year due to
staff changes and available resources to
draft the report
you will note the good progress is being
made relating to health and safety
Arrangements whilst first inspection may
cause concern relating to the increased
number of reported incidents in their
missed reports this is seen as positive
staff are encouraged to report concerns
and issues which can be done anonymously
directly onto a record system which
generates a report for attention and
follow-up
this is being actively used by officers
so we are confident the majority of
accidents near misses and instances of
unacceptable Behavior are being captured
as evidenced by this increase in numbers
myself and my colleague Mr Green will be
happy to answer any questions members
have in relation to this report thank
you
um I think it's an excellent report
members do we have any questions
um I'd like to congratulate you
um Council Hall did you have a question
no no
um I'd like to congratulate you on the
work and the progress that has been made
we certainly know there was issues of
reporting and I won't go into too much
more detail but um well done everybody
who has contributed to this and the
staff
um and whichever officers are
responsible for producing it so the
recommendations are that members
consider the accidents and incident
statistics yes we've got them that
members consider progress with the
health and safety action plan and
appendix one and little two little three
sorry that members consider additional
health and safety improvements being
implemented implemented in addition to
those identified in the action plan what
I would will add before I actually go to
propose in a second uh can we just make
sure that it's all well and good but we
we mitigate we don't just stop Services
because we can't do it or we think that
the risk is too high I'm very conscious
that sometimes it can be taken too far
health and safety and I say that for a
reason and I so propose do I have a
second agreed Council Thompson agreed
thank you
oh thank you yeah
yeah good good agenda item 12 members
we're now cooking on gas
um balance score card with the
exceptions misuse your back again I'm
afraid on this one
um the purpose purpose of this report is
to report exceptions
um to operational service reporting for
committee review and discussion the
corporate performance and governance
framework requires this committee to be
given visibility of any identified
balanced scorecard key performance
indicators which is kpi that have met
their threshold supported by an action
plan to ensure targets are met this
gives assurance that operational
performance is being managed uh
proactively and effectively misused
would you like to whiz through yes so
this is the exception typical that's
provided on a six monthly basis as a
result of monthly monitoring of service
level performance so the report covers
the period of January to June 2022.
section 3.5 on your covering report has
table that shows underperforming
measures and an explanation and
additionally section 3.6 highlights to
over performing areas
additionally appendix one to the report
provides planning service operational
performance data to provide a more
detailed context for this area members
are asked to review and comment on the
report as set out and confirm assurance
that operational performance is being
managed effectively
any questions members
um counselor um stilts and then cancer
Stevens thank you it's not actually a
question it's just an observation it's
looking at the colors on the appendix
one and it's something you alluded to
earlier you look at the colors on
appendix one and you go to the
um PS2 Delta Malden uh page 100.
it they're all very much of a matchness
in those colors can we have something
different
yeah red green yellow and blue or
something wouldn't it there's something
that's so
um yeah I I think is that all right with
you in this weekly take that on board
yeah that's absolutely fine we can come
up with a different color scale so that
it's more easy to see where we fit
within the district that's fine thank
you
um I'm gonna go to council esteems first
then or was that in relation to this no
no go to cancer Stevens then Council
Fleming please
thank you chair
um looking on page 92 and those tables
that start there
um so we can see that where there are
issues but it's it's impossible I think
to tell what how what is the extent of
the problem so we've taken the first one
just as an example percentage of
business rates collected
what what percentage were we aiming for
what did we get what's the problem I
don't understand the size of the problem
and the others the other rows the same
question I don't understand the size of
the problem thank you
um it's a very good point um misuse
could you answer that there's no numbers
there's nothing there to actually
tangible so that you can measure it by
detail
card that's looked at monthly and then
it's obviously reported in
um but I
um
I think what we can do is basically
Trail those
um numbers into the explanation so I'll
take that on board for the next time
that we report it through to you we do
have the number set behind that and I'll
include it again included in the
explanation thank you because it's
really important that we do get the
figures behind we have raised this
before
um that we knew we want to drill down to
actually have something that's tangible
cancer Stevens thank you though I miss
you Chancellor Stevens thank you I mean
obviously some high level numbers in
there would be great but I think you
know we might not all drill down to
every single level but it just put
hyperlinks in and if it takes you to the
right place then if you're really
fascinated in business rates then this
person will drill down there if the next
person's really fascinated in something
else they'll drill down to another thing
I'm not really after trying to make the
agenda 600 Pages longer but the ability
to access the data really would be
appreciated thank you thanks
um councilor Fleming then Council fluka
thank you chair um I just wanted to ask
Cheryl I see that on uh page 93 we've
put in Leisure centers there is that
really I was just quite surprised to see
it there because it's it's not really
separate business isn't it
so uh the reason that that flagged it
was in the commercial income
so it's being it's being monitored as
part of the commercial part of the
operational balance scorecard and that's
due to the
um Chris might be able to announce the
better but the contract Arrangements I
understand and the reason that it's over
performing is because the shortfall was
less than what we were expecting
um but for the Leisure centers
okay thank you
yep so the reason why it's here um Mrs
users uh mentioned uh but it is just a
case of tracking against targets
um that were put there
um in terms of their membership at the
time but it is an area that obviously
we're looking at and also the finance
side of it is very different from the
actual membership side so I think that's
another important indicator that we we
need to have site of which will of
course come through as part of Finance
monitoring
I think you read my mind because that's
exactly where I thought hang on a minute
the alarm Bell rung there um councilor
Fluker yeah
you know based on what was said before
about not being able to recruit into the
planning department and having vacancies
and
and because of that the planning
department not really performing well if
if you look at if you look at appendix
one I mean there's actually nothing
jumps out there to say the planning
department isn't performing well in fact
I think basically on those figures they
should be commended you know you know
this doesn't reflect what comes into my
mailbox I mean the number of
um applications that haven't been uh
validated or determined I mean I think I
think we do need and and if Miss Hughes
has got our ears on uh and I apologize
if I missed it but I think it would be
good to have um some kind of a kpi which
says
um number of uh applications validated
within the time limit
um although I know there's easy ways to
get around that but I mean those figures
aren't bad at all in fact a mischievous
person would say well why are we
planning to spend all this money on the
planning department and what's it really
going to achieve looking at these
figures we you know we could potentially
spend you know three or four members of
Staff probably a minimum of a hundred
thousand pounds for what
I mean if you look at the Baseline which
is what this is
it's not bad at all and and sometimes
you know there's a few figures in here
that do make me smile because I I can't
believe how any local thoughts you can
score 100 in some of these figures but
you know just because we're down the
bottom it doesn't mean to say we're
we're we're doing badly because we're
we're still Incredibly Close to to our
contemporaries in in the county I mean I
I mean chairman I I
really like to meet this planning
consultant who this council's now
pointed at this meeting
um and and go through these figures and
ask him you know
what does he see his outcome is how far
does he want to move these figures and
how much is it going to cost
I think I think it's really obvious
I think at some points well made and I
think the director I think it comes
would it come into Richard Holmes I
think he's I think it's a a very valid
valid point I'm going to go to council
Fleming then councilor Thompson
so I've had a message from someone
listening externally who cannot hear
Council fluke I'm sorry to pick on you
Council but it was you they mentioned
thank you so much thank you
um Council Fleming please thank you just
following on from Council of Luca's
remarks that I'd I would like a bit more
detail actually just
um
I I just how much is it costing what is
their brief
what have they been asked are they going
to write a report
to suit
I would like to know more thank you well
absolutely stake we keep getting told
that we're not recruiting we're not
doing things we're not reaching our kpis
but when you look at those figures that
actually they're hard and fast figures
and and it paints a completely different
picture you know I don't know how much
we're going to invest to move two
percentage points
you know maybe our staff are working 80
hours a week but I've never heard that
um
we have been carrying vacancies pretty
much since we then provided with the
transformation model as you all know
um but the remit of the interim
transformation manager that's coming in
is to draft a report and to present all
possible recommendations
um which you know includes looking at
structure looking at the roles the
grades the retention even the
opportunities for outsourcing so they
are going to be presenting a very full
scope of proposals which will come back
and which we will be bringing to members
so if anybody does want some more detail
I am happy to share that with them the
interim transformation manager starts
with this on Monday next week and in
terms of the cost that was agreed by
members in the last council meeting with
the recommendation that Mr Richard
Holmes put forward thank you um thank
you Miss win I think I think with all in
all fairness to the members of this
committee and councilor fluka
um I we we most probably hadn't been
given the reports or full Council hadn't
been given the report which cancer fluke
is using the data to actually make a
well-constructed argument as far as I
can see but Council Fluker can speak for
himself so I do apologize if I put words
in your mouth there councilor Fluker
to me
the planning department is doing okay
you know chucking another 100 Grand at
it is it really going to improve it that
much I mean I I really don't know in
fact the message that the planning
department should take from this
committee is that we're delighted with
their performance because that's really
really surprised me what's going on
there and I think it will surprise a lot
of members and I think look this the new
Consultants coming on on Monday on
Monday I believe it's only uh it's I
think for four months so one would have
thought 25 of his time due during his
fixed term contract would be a good time
to come to this Committee in a month's
time and perhaps you know we can go
through these figures with him I mean it
is performance and Satan will what are
you expecting to move and where are you
expecting to move so we can then
Benchmark his performance and then going
forward we'll know exactly where we
should be aspiring to my gut feeling is
it's going to be very very difficult to
move some of those figures because they
they tend to they tend to be more
relevant to success of our
contemporaries so if you get simple
planning applications you get everything
done and you get everything through
you're bound to move up the list but
we're not actually it looks like we're
going to be dealing with
uh fewer planning applications this year
than we have done for a number of years
but anyway on I'll stop because I think
my friend on the left one yeah yeah she
does but I think Miss green would like
to come in she's popped up have you got
anything to add
and thank you very much uh chairman I
think I thought I'd just like to add is
that that performance has been achieved
at a cost
um both in terms of the pressure on our
team and also the use of external agency
staff
so I think you know whilst those figures
do look acceptable it is a real cost to
our staff in terms of the hours they
work the pressure that they're under and
the use of external agency style so I'd
just like to just add that to those and
bring that to complete detention thank
you um Council Stevens
thank you and I would just add to that
also that we haven't been providing all
of the services have we so we haven't
been doing everything the duty
we haven't been doing and the
enforcement has been a bit woeful
um anyway the point I wanted to make was
completely different to that
um on page 92 I don't understand this
one about the missed bins it's my
favorite subject Dustin my mailbox is
full of dustbins
um so the issue is missed bins exceeding
the service level agreement so that's
the desire is that
is sort of a double negative isn't it
we've got missed bins exceeding the
service level agreement and they have
exceeded the service level agreement
because of operational absences I think
that might mean that we didn't meet the
service level agreement but I'm really
confused could somebody explain that to
me please thank you
misuse
I was at this weekly
yes I'm happy to answer that one chair
thank you so we know that our
contractors have struggled with
um issues around hdb drivers when there
was a shortage of History drivers at
Stratford with absences due to covid
there's been a number of impacts within
that area that has resulted in not being
able to do all of their collections
during the week as planned so we have
seen a number of different impacts in
terms of those figures it does continue
to be a risk there are still challenges
with you know fuel prices as they are
and trying to recruit people into that
particular sector so there are a number
of reasons as to why there have been a
higher number of admit elections in
recent months
okay
um
um Council counselor um Stevens to come
and then Council Thompson
thank you can I come back on that what
I'm saying is I don't understand what it
states there because yes we know that
all of those problems definitely have
existed so I couldn't imagine that we've
exceeded the SLA
I think it's the wording that um
councilor um Stevens is querying Miss
sweetly exceeding the SLA agreement or
terms
collections that we would set as an
absolute threshold is in a negative
um so therefore if we exceed that then
of course that's where we report on that
I understand your explanation but I
think double negatives are confusing and
I would request that it's expressed a
different way next time please thank you
okay so Thompson thank you cancer
Thompson
um sorry I wasn't planning actually
um others including Council of students
have said it you know it would be nice
to be able to do pre-apps I'm often
asked about pre-apps and it's a problem
for people
um but the main thing that struck me was
the 97 of delegated
um applications and certainly we've
noticed on Northwest we don't have as
many but usually the meetings only
happen at all because of call ins yeah
um and there's a huge overhead to call
ins and I would just like to say of
members for whatever reason uh asking
for fewer of them thank you Santa
and I'm sure the planning offices are
only two happy to see that councilor
Fluker and councilor Fleming look from
an economics point of view based on what
Miss green just said bear in mind people
applicants pay for pre-apps
well to me it feels pretty obvious that
we should get one of our fixed term
contracts employees to deal with the
pre-apps
um you know it makes perfectly good
sense to me I don't think there's a
statutory fee for a pre-app either I do
know that from what I've heard a few
days ago he who shouts loudest gets his
pre-app which I don't like because the
pre-apps should be done in chronological
order otherwise we will be you know I
don't want to sound like Miss Holmes and
Mr quilts but you know we could be
subject to Jr if we don't do them in the
correct order this has apparently
happened down at Brighton and just one
thing on uh
pays you 105.
um I think to the right hand side that
should be a waiting confirmation but
appeal number three
um
that wasn't Southeast committee
um that was actually full Council full
Council it was a district planning
committee and those figures actually
aren't right because they don't include
our costs
and there was it's quite a lot more
costs in both of those but yeah but
yeah apart from the big one I think it's
to be expected really but that is a huge
amount of money so
so uh yeah I'll park it there okay all
right common members what's we're all
going to be here
thank you chair I was I just wanted to
ask um Miss green if she could provide
the committee with
um the cost how much we've been paying
temp staff for planning if you could
send that
if you could uh send that to the chair
or circulate to the committee I'd be
quite interested and it would put that
report in context because we can we're
just commenting on how pleased we are
with the figures but how much is it
costing us if you could provide that
information for us that would be much
appreciated thank you okay Miss Green
did you catch that
is
an update
um the ehsc costs are met through our
vacant salaries
um budget but yes we can provide a
breakdown okay that's something that
we're required to report anyway okay
brilliant thank you okay members unless
you want to add anything
um to the recommendations uh that the
committee review and comment on
exceptions to service reporting provided
in this report little two that members
note the additional performance in
appendix so appendix one and that
members confirmed they are assured
through this review operational
performance is being managed effectively
ISO proposes does anybody want to amend
anything no seconded by cancer stilts
agreed members
okay thank you very much
um agenda item 13 this is misused again
the purpose of this report is to provide
an updated risk management policy for
adoption to address
um risk to address the recent risk audit
but there's a lot of hours in this
report to address recent risk audit
recommendations through the revision of
our corporate risk management approach
um Miss Hughes can you please reword it
better next time so there's not so many
hours in it thank you
so um the risk management policy was due
for a renewal by November 2022 as it's
refreshed every 3 years and it's defined
in the PGA committee terms of reference
that the strategy signed off by this
committee as you've got responsibility
for risk management
the committee recently received an
internal audit for risk maturity from
BDO and it gave a good level of
assurance but it also highlighted some
best practice suggestions as I mentioned
earlier such as tracking and being clear
on mitigating actions and also being
clearer for officers on how to score for
likelihood and consequence when they
report risks and so those
recommendations have been incorporated
into this latest version of the policy
the committee is asked to adopt the
revised risk management policy and
recommend all staff and member mandatory
e-learning training for risk
uh thank you Mr Leslie do you like to
say anything on this or are you um okay
um no I'm okay I think Mrs uh he uses
summed it up but happy to take any
questions okay members do we have any
questions
we all agree and the recommendations are
that the revised risk management policy
appendix Aid to be adopted little two
that the committee recommends mandatory
annual staff and member e-learning on
risk management totally agree with the
training thank you very much do I have a
seconder councilor Thompson seconded do
we agree members
thank you very much and a gender item 14
is the annual purpose of the report is
the annual governance statement actions
update
um to update the committee on actions
identified in the 2022-23 2023 annual
government statement
um Miss Hughes I think it's oh it's not
your last one you've got one after this
as well you're nearly there my love
um yeah so in the annual governance
statement we identify actions to improve
best practice across the organization
and So within this report section 3.5
highlights the updates against those
actions and that's based on three months
of activity since the statement was
approved uh four more actions are
reported as completed and there's a
further six in progress
commentaries provided for members for
you to review and challenge thank you
members
no oh
crikey okay so the recommendation is
there's only one that the committee
reviews the annual government statement
table and updates below and challenges
where necessary well there's been no
challenges I think we actually agree I
propose it do I have a secondary cancer
stilts do we agree members
agreed
right Cheryl it's the last one for you
my love okay gender item 15 I thought it
was going to be Stuart and but I've been
told it's you
um Council Constitution and scheme of
Delegation a general Provisions update
the purpose of the report is to seek the
committee's consideration of a proposed
revision to the above Powers within the
Constitution and to recommend the cut to
the council that the revision is made
Mrs would you like to just report the
last uh present the last report
yeah so the council's adopted Financial
regulations acknowledge that directors
and other budget holders are authorized
to incur expenditure from an approved
budget
and so for the avoidance of any doubt
and to give it added status for internal
administrative purposes it is felt this
should appear within the scheme of
Delegation under General powers in this
section of the Constitution
this in no way extends or transfers
delegated powers as such and the
proposed wording is set in terms
designed to ensure proper use of the
general authorization The Proposal was
supported by the corporate governance
working group at its last meeting and
it's presented to members to review
okay the recommendation is that the
committee agrees direct and recommends
to the council that the proposed Edition
to be made be made to part three
responsibility of four functions scheme
of Delegation General Provisions as
detailed in paragraph 3.4 below do I
have um a second for that
um cancer Thompson and do we have any
questions sorry I've moved on a bit
quickly no no questions do we agree
members okay
um finally members any other items of
business that the chairman of the
committee decides are Urgent I have none
so I close this meeting at 9 36 I think
it is is it I've got the wrong glasses
on thank you thank you members very